really hard absolutely it is it is
and for alex by the way had the patience
that he showed this gaining of time on
the clock and just for you know keeping
the pressure
offering
problems problems solve this one oh you
sold that well then we'll solve
this new problem
and the constructions that uh he made
the right moves at the right moment by
the way let's just make it
pressure make a point before we see the
standings
it was move
29
29
when they went into this end game wow
111 moves
wow they went into this annual move 29
111 moves later before
the victory unbelievable
just simply incredible what a titanic
struggle after those results let's start
with the ladies let's look at the
standings start with the ladies we have
one leader in the lady section katarina
nenzova irina crush karissa
nasi paikidze and gulruk begimtohironova
as well as ashrita isran following
closely behind with three points only
half a point and in the open section
please
christian in the open section we have
two co-leaders we have ray robson
and the man of the hour alex landerman
wesley sew and lanier dominguez
following closely behind and we see
fabiano caruana
one point one full point behind the
leader absolutely but we have an
exhausted but exhilarated
player with us
alex lander one is with maurice
alex we won't keep you long
congratulations on your win
you enter this end game on move 29 could
you have imagined it would take 111
moves before you finally
sealed the deal well i mean there's
about such positions they say you know
suffering 400 moves so this time it was
not actually an
exaggeration there was a hundred moves
no but i think at some point i thought i
should have been winning much easier but
somehow he defended very well and i
couldn't find that
clear plan and i was spending a lot of
time and maybe at some point he
it was already even a draw but it was
still tricky to play so
no it was a lucky break of course not to
have spoiled it what is your mindset
going into this kind of position at some
point we saw you shuffling back and
forth fourth and back trying to make
sure you didn't repeat
what right in the middle of that tension
what was your mindset
well um you know the key is not to make
a mistake and put them under pressure
sometimes in a position like that when
opponent has no counterplay the russian
school method is just to shuffle pieces
around make slight improvements and also
make opponent feel like nothing is
threatened but then at some point they
make an accuracy and then you pounce
it's a well-known strategy in such
positions but of course i feel like if i
would have found a clearer plan
then um i would have played it better
but okay i did
the best i could i guess
i'm looking at you and it seems like you
could have played another 20 30 40 moves
is that the case or are you feeling
pretty exhausted well i feel like i'm
still quite fresh thankfully i'm just a
bit hungry because i couldn't get any
more snacks because of the time pressure
um yeah so it was a very tense game but
you know i was ready to play as long as
it took to try to and i was it was good
that i was able to move that pawn one
more time to get rid of the 50 move
rules so that's
kind of important
no i mean of course i was very happy
with the way the opening went it was a
slight advantage no risk to lose not
just
for two results so last question for you
your type of first
after five rounds you've been in first
place before in this championship what's
going to make this one any different
well i just uh i think
i'm older player now so more experienced
so i think
i'll be able to handle this uh situation
a bit better
yeah i think also the tournament is much
stronger now than i think the last time
i had realistic chances to win it was in
2014.
back before there was there was no five
you know wesley carter didn't play
obviously no dominguez it was a
different type of tournament and i had
actually a realistic chance to win till
the very end
but then i lost two games in a row after
round five you know i was i guess i
i made some mistakes in my approach at
some point and then i kind of battled
back i won two games and i was still in
contention but yeah this time no i'm not
really thinking about the result just
yet i mean it's still too early in the
tournament that anything can still
pretty much happen like uh
so i think it's it's still way too early
to think about who's leading and stuff
like that
i think at this point you have to just
do the best you can and
hopefully that will be enough to for a
good place
well we're the commentators we have to
think about who's leading
but for you indeed keep up the good play
you do play ray robson tomorrow two
leaders going at it apparently is that
correct
oh it's ray tomorrow i i thought it
might be it was darius but i guess i
confused my parents odds so it's rate
tomorrow interesting your experience
with him
um well in general i've done quite well
against him surprisingly even though
he's a very good player uh but although
recently in some in the last few over
the board games he's done i think better
um against me he's won
a game that i probably shouldn't have
lost so and he's definitely improving he
did very well in the online championship
as well so
like it's it's gonna be a tough game but
you know with black you know i'll just
have to do the best i can and see what
happens battle the leaders tomorrow
congratulations on your result today and
good luck in your game thank you
congratulations congratulations what a
game what a game what a day what a day
just great stuff
i'm still i
you know it's funny the more